it looks like your whole family has been  getting into tick-tock dances  true yes you know my my daughter  especially during this whole time it's  been a great outlet for her she's  turned into like a little paul abdul  which we're doing the little dance and  then she got the whole family in on the  act  yeah and now i feel like we're like the  little uh latino partridge family right  there  that's my wife and my son dominique get  the baby baby bjorn  oh my gosh yeah so she's you know she  puts these all together and we start  breaking it down  i cannot even stand your wife right now  i want to have that body without working  for it oh my god oh my god your whole  family is adorable  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever help